que tienen en común estas situaciones el
chorro de agua que se genera en una
fuente el tiro de un jugador de golf y
el lanzamiento de un boomerang
si pensaste en algo relacionado con
movimiento felicidades
si dibujamos la trayectoria de estos
movimientos se forma la figura de una
parábola es decir una de las
características de una función
cuadrática
aquí vemos la parábola representada en
una gráfica
y esta gráfica podría ser de una función
cuadrática
la respuesta es no porque en una función
cuadrática la dirección de la parábola
es única y en esta gráfica se tiene más
de una dirección una parábola puede ser
cóncava cuando tiene los brazos hacia
arriba o convexa cuando están hacia
abajo también puede ser simétrica ya que
si marcamos un eje de simetría los
puntos que tenemos de un lado del plano
los encontraremos también en el otro
por último hablemos sobre el vértice que
es el punto de intersección entre el eje
de simetría y los brazos de la parábola
una función cuadrática en realidad es
una ecuación de segundo grado
fx es igual a x al cuadrado más bx más c
decimos que es de segundo grado porque
el mayor exponente que encontramos es el
2 cada término de la ecuación tiene un
nombre a x al cuadrado es el término
cuadrática porque tenemos el exponente
elevado al cuadrado
v x es el término lineal ya que este
determinará las coordenadas o brazos de
la parábola y c es el término
independiente el cual brindará la
orientación de la parábola
en la formula fx es igual a x al
cuadrado más bx más donde a es distinto
de cero las literales o términos a b y c
pueden ser cualquier número
recuerda estas sencillas reglas siempre
es distinto de cero como en la primera
ecuación donde a es igual a 5 b y c si
pueden ser 0 aunque en esta ecuación si
tenemos el término cuadrática se está
omitiendo el término b y en la segunda
ecuación no tenemos el tercer término
ahora cada vez que realices un salto o
veas a una persona haciendo un tiro de
basquetbol podrás ver la representación
de la parábola de una función cuadrática